everyone good evening welcome my name is
Mark tribe I'm director of art and
technology in the School of the Arts and
I want to welcome you to the art and
Technology lectures for the fall
semester of 2004 and I want to let you
know first about the upcoming lectures
we have Jeffrey canard on the
twenty-eighth of October he's an
intellectual property lawyer
specializing in legal issues that arise
in new media environments siva
vaidyanathan is going to speak on
November eighteenth siva is a professor
at NYU in culture and communications and
published a book that's very relevant to
the subject called copyrights and copy
wrongs and also a newer book called the
anarchist in the library John applet oh
who is a curator at the Guggenheim
Museum here in New York and our artist
and also a professor at the University
of Maine where he runs their new media
center he will speak on December second
and cory arcangel who's a computer
artist who hacks around with obsolete
video game hardware like Game Boys and
Nintendo's will speak on December 16th
all the lectures will take place
thursday nights 6pm here except for the
last one which will be over in dodge
hall in the leroy neiman gallery our
lectures from last semester are
available online we have a website for
this lecture series just google columbia
art and technology lectures and if you
miss any of the upcoming lectures you'll
also be able to find them online shortly
you know within a couple two three weeks
after each lecture wanted to thank the
Center for new media teaching and
learning for working with us to produce
the streaming video for the website and
also the computer music center for
helping support the series the topic of
the art technology lectures this
semester is open-source culture
intellectual property technology in the
arts artists have always imitated and
emulated one another but starting
sometime in the beginning of the 20th
century a new mode of creative practice
began to emerge rather than creating
their work X nilo from nothing from
scratch artists began to sample
appropriate found materials might think
about Picasso and Braque pasting bits of
news print newspaper onto their canvases
or the readymades of Marcel Duchamp pop
art etc right onto DJ music and and net
art more recently the idea is to look at
these kinds of appropriate of artistic
practices through the lens of
open-source software which is software
that's whose source code is made
available to the public rather than held
as a proprietary secret to sort of see
how technology has functioned to enable
the emergence of these news forms of
artistic practice and look at what kinds
of commonalities there might be between
these technological practices of open
source and these more cultural practices
it is with great pleasure tonight that I
introduce joy Garnett our first lecture
who's going to open up the series joy is
the editor of news Grist which is a blog
weblog that focuses on art politics and
digital culture she also is the author
editor producer of the bomb project
which is a incredible web resource a
kind of trove of images and links and
other kinds of resources texts relating
to nuclear weapons it's seen as a
resource for artists and activists who
want to make work that's engaged
politically with issues around nuclear
weapons in nuclear warfare and it's an
incredible resource I recommend you
check it out just google the bomb
project you'll find it but joy is also
an accomplished painter and
that's really what brings her here
tonight she had a solo show last year at
debs in company called riot in which he
produced paintings that were based on
images that she sampled from the web and
we're going to hear about her brush with
the long arm of intellectual property
law with that I introduce joy Garnett
okay mmm I I'm calling this lecture
painting mass media because it's become
part of what I do and I decided to
describe fair use as an art because it
seems to become more and more of an art
as intellectual property law becomes
more and more of like just litigious
area and although it's described as in
the Constitution as as a limitation of
copyright it's more and more difficult
to to know just where fair use begins
and ends and with that I am I had
produced a series of paintings based on
on newspaper images for her show called
riot is mark described and I had a brush
with the law
and before I go into those sources those
mass media sources I just want to say a
few things about sources in general and
and my method in terms of the sources I
look for in order to make a series of
paintings before i got into mass media
meaning newspaper magazine web
photojournalistic images of real things
going on in the world I I spent a long
time sampling images first from
videotapes that i bought from the
government and then later i just went
straight to the web and i found that
there was a large amount of d classified
material that had been released in the
into the public domain and that was
available for which you didn't have to
ask permission and unless you were going
to create a commercial project a movie
or or something like that and at that
stage i was interested in the the
problem of government secrecy and how
that mediated our knowledge of certain
historical events and how after the
disclosure of documentation of those
events how that affected our
understanding of them and i created a
series of paintings and that also
eventually led to the creation of the
bomb project website generally i came to
learn to use google and other search
engines and just search wildly for
different things that were mostly from
government and military sites images
like that interested in me this was
before nine eleven and i would transmute
them into paintings and it was pretty
much my sense that what i was doing with
painting was was a play on or a critique
of how how
media images affect us or or don't
affect us and I guess it's my contention
that the medium really does determine
how how the viewer deals with the image
and so painting the same image that one
sees or perhaps whoops or perhaps
doesn't register as well as one finds it
in the mass media allows the viewer to
engage the image with with a different
part of themselves because painting has
baggage there's historical baggage so
you actually approach a painting whereas
images in the mass media are generally
things you don't approach in the same
way they kind of move through you or
over you and are forgotten anyway I
found a vast array of sources and some
of them allowed me to go into their
directories like this this was an
incredible source for first Gulf War
imagery and that this particular army
lab shot off the television set as it
was happening and that was a while ago
and I made some paintings from those I
found it was possible to to capture to
save QuickTime movies and mpegs and
choose stills from those from which I
made a series of works and it seemed
that the way those images were couched
or presented affected would affect the
way that the viewer internalized them
and so painting would also affect that I
i chose some sources which had a you
know commercial from from the commercial
world i guess the discovery channel was
a great source of
declassified war imagery and and where
it might be sensationalized there it
turned into something else once it was
translated into paint some things left
out some things left in well all this
online searching leads you into places
you really never knew you were going to
in the first place and I guess it's
important to say that my sources really
do establish the conceptual framework
for each project so so that that
previous project had to do very much
with sources being hidden and then
disclosed released into the public
domain and and the project was therefore
very much about how we internalize
things that had been kept from us this
project is kind of the opposite it's
more about images that were buffeted
with that stream through our lives and
that we almost don't register that that
are forgotten quickly and it was pretty
much my intention to to try and retrieve
lost media images and rework them as
paintings that would stop them and make
them more interfaces for reflection if
you would Google is good because it it's
sort of level it's a leveler and you
find all kinds of things you just plug
in a word like rioters or war or
explosion or bomb or unrest or protest
or demonstration and you get all kinds
of things you get etchings you get
things from in Anarchy sites indymedia
mainstream news sites are all kinds of
things and I began to feel that so many
of these images which really we see
ourselves depicted needed to be captured
somehow and painting seemed the perfect
route a more self a more obviously
self-reflexive medium so this is just a
look into my files and I collect these
things I put them away sometimes I
change their title in the file sometimes
I just leave them and depending on
whether I've I've left their original
title I often forget where they came
from what the original context was and
and this is important for me and it's
important in this discussion of media
imagery because the image itself
contains no intrinsic or ethical rigor
it does not tell you by itself what it
means what it wants you to move it's
there for a wild thing and images
released into the media even though
their original context may have a very
specific in particular meeting meant to
sway you in this way or the other once
they're out there they're out there and
they can be cropped and their meaning
changed and point of view really is
everything sometimes and if you don't
know where it came from it means maybe
so many things and then once you know it
means a very specific thing and this is
this is just some background as to how I
got into this in the first place so and
I'm not first obviously and clearly
there have been many artists who've used
photographic material for many years for
many decades for centuries really and
there's even some treatment of how
Vermeer used a camera obscura and and so
on but I'm going to just limit this to
painters we probably are familiar with
artists who've used journalistic
photographs in order to comment
in our society on our culture the most
obvious Andy Warhol whoo-hoo used news
photographs who used well he used
everything he used what we would
consider to be part of our cultural
heritage things from the public domain
to comment various ways on our culture
Gerhard Richter the German painter did
does this with everything but the he
made a very famous series of works on
the baader-meinhof group which was a
extreme leftist group in Germany that
was sort of like a kind of weather
underground type organization and and he
used photographs of the baader-meinhof
in jail and they were very controversial
photographs to begin with and the
paintings themselves were extremely
controversial when they were publicized
and as you can see just from those
slides let's go back just for a second
well what happens when you look is very
different when you look at the painting
even this JPEG of painting of Gerhard
Richter's there's a different level of
engagement between the viewer and the
image then there would have been from a
news photograph Leon golub possibly the
only painter of his generation who
treated the Vietnam War um in his art on
such a grand scale on such a thorough
scale used he had cabinets full of
scraps of newspapers magazines things he
kept and
I found this magnificent quote which
I'll read just part of I'm nuts on
images I cut them out of books and
newspapers mostly books and magazines
and this is absolutely crucial to me
because this is one of the ways i tap
into the world it goes on to say I see
the world because it comes to me through
media through film through newspapers
through TV were surfeited really we're
overexposed were shoved out all the time
by media and I've and I've often said
it's kind of a half joke you know how
they say you're sixty or eighty percent
water well actually we're made up of
25,000 photographs 11,000 films all of
this has moved through us and is
affecting us in some way or the other so
we're media creatures we're living in an
extraordinary visual world I want to do
a certain kind of reporting a certain
kind of reportage this is the way things
were at this particular moment in time
the moment being the 20th 21st century
this is where I'm situated when I look
out this is what I see I'm not
interested in abstract notions of beauty
I'm not interested in formalism i'm
interested in beauty because due to my
perverted sense of things i think of
this as beautiful I really do so I had
to quote that cuz I really do feel Leon
gollub maybe more than a lot of these
other artists is a kind of them well a
mentor and an example to me and I feel
very much moved by his ideas and his
work more recently and in fact on
through mid-october at the Q Art
Foundation is an artist from Canada
named Stephen Andrews who recently
collected some of those notorious Abu
Ghraib photographs and made some very
interesting rubbings based on them
rubbings I can't tell you exactly how he
does them but he uses them some kind of
surface so that he he can make more
obvious the the technological interface
that
that we meet when we view newspaper and
magazine images he calls attention to
that surface to the to the mediation
going on and I won't read all this but
he basically searched the internet found
these photographs he told me that he was
looking for pornography to do a
pornography project and when he found
these he thought this is this is
pornography enough I'll I'll do this
project and the point I suppose of
talking about these these works is is to
show how many ways artists who aren't
even connected by generation or culture
utilize reutilization and material that
exists in the public domain that we all
experience in a day-to-day way and and
this is this is the stuff that we
experiment with and a great deal of this
stuff goes into the garbage but the
freedom to use this stuff to sample it
appropriate it whatever you want to call
it is is part of the creative process
and it's not just artists to use it and
we utilize it once the stuff is out in
the world everybody can get to it
especially now and and it gets reused in
interesting ways that might be my
favorite and artists like richard serra
created uncharacteristic images from
that particular photograph this is
downloadable add a website and he sent
out a message saying you know download
this image and plaster it everywhere and
during the the protests against the
Republican convention in New York I saw
a lot of people with this placard
kind of interesting Richard Serra go now
Steve Mumford is someone who kind of did
the opposite he decided not to rely on
these mediated images that come from
war-torn places that are found in the
media but he went there he's there now
and he's been there he's been going back
and forth since since we invaded Iraq
and i just thought i put this image
first it's called adjusting sites which
is kind of perfect um and so in a way
he's doing what photo journalists do but
he's also doing what painters do and
being there I wonder if he has trouble
creating enough distance creating enough
mediation so that he can do the work I
don't know but um their effect i think
is very different from photojournalism
and of course they're presented as art
their art they're more art than
reportage probably
if anyone hasn't read this book it's a
very and is interested in this whole
argument about images in in the mass
media and the photo journalistic mission
to change the world and how truthful and
image is this is a very good read and
it's a very short book and it's a very
dense with questions and this is sort of
a core of this talk that the same
photograph can be read in a million ways
the minute the photojournalist shoots
the image his intention his or her
intention in a way is is gone is lost
even with copyright protection even with
agencies such as Magnum once the
photograph is in the world it has a life
of its own
now these these are photos are
photojournalistic photographs and I
haven't attributed them because I don't
know who take took them because they
come from my file and this is what I do
I don't save all that information I just
grabbed JPEGs and I shove them in a file
and months later or weeks later or day
later I print them out and I stick them
in an actual manila file and then I
choose certain ones to paint some of
them can't possibly make a good painting
some of them can it's it's a judgment
call it's hard to say sometimes you
think you're doing the right thing and
you make a crappy painting you throw it
out but the point is you need to feel
that you have the leeway to to play
because art is play and so here was my
problem that i didn't know i had and
maybe it's not a problem um depending on
who you are every single image that you
just saw in that an unattributed series
is copyrighted they're all copyrighted
so but they're different they're
different than say a photograph that an
artist makes in their studio where they
have actors and props and where the
entire thing is really a product of
expression and in fact that's a term
that is going to be used again and again
in the law and in discussion of fair use
expression versus idea and there's a
concept called the the idea expression
dichotomy which we'll talk about in a
second but the point of fair use is that
copyright is important but it should be
limited in certain circumstances in
order to allow for free exchange
information research reporting
creativity
and in the Copyright Act it's very it's
a tradition and it's in the law that
copyright does not apply to facts it
does not apply to ideas if you write
about a certain idea and someone copies
what you wrote and says and puts their
name on it that's copyright infringement
but if they write about the idea itself
it's not and a very dumb example in the
visual arts would be Ansel Adams took a
photograph of a mountain that photograph
is copyrighted but other people are
allowed to photograph that mountain so
that's a dumb example this like really
obvious object in the public domain
cannot be copyrighted but where does
expression begin and end and where does
fact begin an end and that's the problem
it's very subjective and I think it will
always be subjective there's no way to
really pin that down its point of view
it's what you need it's what you feel is
that is the issue back to my files
sometimes I look at the thumbnails or I
look at the printouts and I see one and
I feel the inclination to paint it and I
guess someday last summer I saw this guy
and I thought yeah he's great and I
printed him out and I made a 70 inch
tall painting and then I forgot about it
I put it in my storage and i made other
paintings and eventually though I went
back to it and I made a whole series of
figures based on news images news images
I had collected from all kinds of places
mainstream news sites anarchist webpages
crazy conspiracy sites the New York
Times all kinds of places and
I made a series and lo and behold the
gallery that then existed that doesn't
exist anymore that used to represent me
said let's do this let's do this as a
show and we decided to call it riot and
here are some of the details of some of
the paintings that were in it and they
are pain early transformative well
there's a legal term painterly
transformations of found media images
that stripped entirely of their original
context in order to show other things
but loyal to some degree to the original
text to the original photographs to some
degree to reference their origin to
reference that medium to reference the
difference between this medium in that
medium because I'm a compulsive archiver
I I put all I put JPEGs of all of my
paintings on a website where i can
access them where other people can
access them if i need someone to write
an article or to write something on a
painting i can just email them the URL
it's very convenient and galleries these
days either have blogs or websites so
they can announce their shows and it's
sort of a convention so this was my
galleries webpage and they had the press
release and various paintings that were
in the show there and show opened
mid-january early februari I got a
really strange email from an
acquaintance um someone I I've never met
but with whom I had a correspondence at
one time because I had wanted to it's a
photojournalist who publishes his
photographs in book form and some of
them interested me and i thought i would
ask permission not my usual mo and he
this was a while before and he really
didn't feel comfortable and so we forgot
about it and I hadn't heard from him
since then and he sent me this um Susan
my zealous is going to visit with me in
my studio later this week I have the
postcard from your show up by my desk as
you know this is from one of her
photographs in Nicaragua does she know
about this I assume she must yadda yadda
yadda I don't want to get in the middle
of this but i do think i'll take it down
so he had this over his desk who knows
if he ever took it down Susan my zealous
evidently did give him a studio visit or
maybe she didn't but anyway I was
surprised I had no idea I was calling I
was calling this guy the Basque I guess
that's kind of stupid he has a beret my
original fragment didn't show the rifle
the sandbags the two other figures the
tank the palm tree or the dog patch
behind him it's very different when you
see all these things I was kind of
thrilled or the wound and the bandage on
his rifle holding arm so he's not a kid
in a rabble throwing Molotov he's a
revolutionary with an incredibly large
gun surrounded by other revolutionaries
a tank and sandbags he's ascending nista
and this friend of mine sent me the URL
so i could see this image on the magnum
site because Susan my zealous is a
magnum photographer she is part of that
organization that that agency that
basically was created in 1947 as a way
to protect and promote the careers of
photojournalists by giving them
copyright protection by allowing them to
be part of a club whereby they would be
protected and where their images would
be sent out to maybe news wires or
published in book form but basically
it's a very um magnum it's a very famous
very important very traditional
organization
and well as you can see there's Magnum
water marks all over this image and they
have all of their photographs their
photographers photographs online and I
work my way backwards and I found where
this photograph came from and it's from
a book that Susan Mizell is published in
nineteen eighty one of 71 images that
she took from inside the revolution in
Nicaragua she photographed the regime
individuals in the regime individuals
the revolutionaries she was very much
sympathetic to the revolution she was
very much part of the movement here that
was disgusted with what our government
the part our government played in that
story and her book is an homage to the
revolutionaries and her images never
went out on newswires they were
presented in this form which is really
an art form although they were reportage
she was reporting on what was going on
there and she lived there for ten years
dodging bullets so what I'm trying to
say is this person who threatened me
with a lawsuit eventually I have total
respect for um but in other words she's
the precursor to the Steve Mumford's who
go there with their little pads and
she's an artist but she's a reporter
she's straddling the two worlds um now I
I kind of was I was very peeved at this
ominous email telling me that I had done
something wrong because I I really
really didn't think I had and plus I was
um you know interested in her work it
was kind of an accident I wouldn't have
gone to a book of a photojournalist and
looked for a photograph and then made a
painting from that my project is kind of
the opposite I don't want well known
photographs I don't want photographs
that are considered or presented as art
I want the opposite I want lost news
footage stuff that no one remembers at
my opening there were people from around
the art world including a
friend who's a curator at the
international center for photography in
New York ICP and he either didn't notice
that it was from that painting a sorry
from that photograph or he didn't care
or it didn't matter or didn't register
paintings very large photograph is in a
book never said anything I made the huge
mistake of mentioning this to my
photographer friend who really really
took umbrage and wrote me this he was
clearly disgusted i went to magnum i
look at their copyright you can go
online and look at their their copyright
policy yeah my friend freaked out or
well I'm presenting it in a freakout way
I it was a sore point with him and as
someone who had to make their living as
a hack for magazines or doing commercial
photography I totally sympathize I mean
but at least they make their living it's
interesting how well they only point I'm
going to make with this is this
interesting how we all we all struggle
as artists we do our thing and we
perceive others as the ones who make the
money and it's just a kind of knee-jerk
reaction and possibly although I'm you
know at the beginning of my career my
paintings don't sell very much yet but
it was perceived a show in a gallery in
Chelsea you know this is a man who lives
in Minneapolis Susan my zealous is like
probably eating sand and Iraq right now
I mean these are people who struggle to
but the perception of a show in a
gallery in Chelsea i supposes is is not
one of struggling from far away so and i
just want to point out that his
statement that Warhol always asked for
protect for permission is not true and
that this particular painting he was
threatened with a lawsuit over by the
photographer by the news photographer
and he
settled that lawsuit by giving the news
photographer another painting with
photographs by some other footage
analyst but but that that's a case in
point because I think artists and people
with sense like enough sense not to go
to court or not have money to go to
court tend to want to settle things out
of court so the bad side of edits there
isn't really any case law there is very
little case law that protects fair use
in the visual arts because when when
people get sued all right if you go to
court and you lose damages can be up to
for that for copyright infringement of
that sort can be up to a hundred
thousand dollars if you win you've been
paying your lawyer probably almost half
that for however long it takes in the
end it's it's not worth it unless you
have a landmark case and you're fighting
you know the good fight for copyleft and
you feel that you can make progress for
the cause most people are not going to
go to court I didn't go to court I was
advised to stay out of court here's just
the the definition once again our fair
use copyright owner's rights are limited
by a principle known as fair use under
the Copyright Act fair use extends to
purposes such as criticism comment news
reporting teaching scholarship and
research now none of those things
criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship and research are
specifically mentioned in the case law
that exists the only thing specifically
that you can really get away with is
parity and that comes up again and again
did you use that image for parity and if
you can prove it was parody it's usually
obvious then they don't have a case but
if you use it to comment on something
else other than the original I mean I
was not commenting on the original
photograph I didn't even have the whole
photograph I was using it to comment on
many other things mass media our culture
freedom fighters whatever you want to
bring to that painting
it's something else and including things
that I didn't intend because painting is
very much more open-ended usually and
it's more about what the viewer brings
so one thing I need to point out right
here is news reporting and fair use
photojournalists operate under the
principle of fair use they don't have to
ask permission they don't get releases
they take their photographs and those
photographs go out and just to be
thorough there are four cardinal points
of fair use that are argued exclusively
of one another and the the extreme
murkiness of of the area becomes
apparent because they're all very
they're all very subjective other than
whether number one the purpose and
character of the use whether it's
commercial or nonprofit even that if
you've created a transformative work
that has some commercial value because
let's face it almost everything in our
culture we try to get to have some kind
of commercial value it doesn't
necessarily mean that you've infringed
so if something goes to court these four
things are kind of put through the
wringer by both both councils and the
last one number for the effect of the
use on the potential market or value of
the original work that's the most
important are you stealing money are you
stealing money from the original person
from there from the copyright owner are
you taking their market away are you
putting your name on their photograph
saying it was yours and selling it
that's really what that's about so now
these four cardinal points were given to
me by my lawyer and then I went online
and did some research and I found them
again and again and again um the other
important one before I go on is number
two the nature of the copyrighted work
whether it's creative or informative and
that brings up again the expression idea
the idea expression dichotomy and is the
copyrighted work is it a work of art is
it pure expression or is it
is it informative is it news is it
reporting is it is it of historical
value is it of the public record
photojournalism is both it's both so
that makes it all really complicated it
straddles both how much of each where
does expression end okay um just to
hearken back I just want to make sure I
don't sound like I'm beating up
photojournalists because I'm not but
this is the concern this seemed to be
the nugget of concern my friend from
Minneapolis when I originally had asked
him if I could use one of his images for
a painting this is why he felt I
shouldn't and I backed off but basically
the idea that it would compete the
misunderstanding that they were to that
there are two different entities two
different quantities that they function
differently he couldn't see that I
didn't argue it with him because I
didn't really want to be limited by
someone else someone else's nervousness
so I dropped the whole idea of ever
asking anyone for mission for permission
ever again not worth it um anyway very
shortly after all of this I received it
was right after my show came down i
received a legal letter my gallery
received a fax legal letter and I got
one by email and then we got hard copies
it was very interesting because I really
didn't expect it and this is the core of
it the core of it is that I had stolen
this image that I had pirated the image
that um that it was a derivative image
derivative image derivative is a legal
terminology that we all use very
casually I said or I used to say I
derived this painting from that
photograph I don't say that anymore
because that that would tell you that I
had created derivative rather than trend
formative works mismas Ellis wanted me
to take the images off the website and I
think that was probably in the end the
only thing that mattered I didn't get
sued I just got threatened but i felt
quite freaked out because um it was what
if every single photo journalist in the
world came at me i would have to do
something else they sent me this xerox
of the original which I had seen which
didn't look like much of anything I went
back I looked I thought about it whilst
one recognizes that artists often pay
homage to other artists copying of this
kind constitutes copyright infringement
you are simply sailing under the flag of
piracy taking verbatim protected
artistic expression so her counsel was
banking on on the description of the
original as artistic expression period
and the use of the word piracy is really
interesting because piracy piracy is
about piracy isn't used in that way
piracy is used to describe someone who
download something in its entirety and
sells it or keeps it or shares it
without paying that's not quite what i
did so i went to a lawyer that was um
suggested to me who was a champion of
fair use who only works with artists and
i asked him my pirate and i didn't just
ask him actually before i went to the
lawyer the day before i went to the
lawyer i opened the whole case up for
discussion without naming names because
i was really paranoid and i am i sent an
email to the rhizome raw listserv where
I've been corresponding and posting and
writing and arguing since the late 90s
and where artists digital artists
educators
and various media people kind of
converge and discuss things and the week
before everyone had been discussing the
grey album so I thought you know okay my
pirate I'm a painter and people were
incensed and there was a long discussion
that ensued and at this stage I was sort
of resigned to my fate that I was caught
in some kind of legal thing that I
didn't understand I didn't know what to
me I thought at that stage that fair use
just meant that you could you know shoot
slides out of an art history book and
give a lecture and you wouldn't have to
ask permission um I brought images but
both images all the images to the lawyer
and we had this discussion
transformative or derivative and he
convinced me that it was a very
subjective thing he felt that there was
a lot of hoopla being made that his word
over this this case of mind that it was
silly that it wasn't worth her while to
sue me she wasn't losing anything by me
having a painting in a gallery show was
down but she wanted complete control of
the purported derivative work if I
wanted to exhibit again if i wanted to
reproduce it in a magazine if someone
wanted to do an article and reproduce it
i would have to get her permission in
writing first according to her lawyer
and he said don't don't sign that form
you don't have to sign that form it's
not a derivative work they don't have a
slam-dunk case and probably neither do
you because it depends on the judge but
we agreed that because I I respect Susan
my zealous and really meant no harm that
I would I would always credit her if or
I would creditor on my website because
the images were on my website I didn't
agree to take them down well so we wrote
we crafted together a long letter that
was not contentious but basically not
giving in one hundred percent and the
core of that letter and the core of my
sense of these things now is that um is
this last part this last portion any
photograph regardless of how literal it
might be is affected by the personal
influence of the photographer but news
photographs are in a category by
themselves because because of the public
interest because they exist mostly in
the public domain they affect public
opinion they're part of our cultural
heritage they belong to everyone to some
degree so we left it at that an apology
promised to credit her and refusal to
sign the form saying that i created a
derivative work and that i would ask for
her permission if I wanted to exhibit it
again seemed good but no so there were
there was an exchange of nasty letters
and nasty phone calls um I decided to
take my image oh right just one more
example of bad case law bad precedence
Jeff Koons sorry I'm getting ahead of
myself just really quickly Jeff Koons
found this photograph in a tourist shop
which had been commissioned for two
hundred and fifty dollars and he made he
got three sorry he got Italian artisans
to make three huge polychrome wood
sculptures um each of which was valued
at 125 thousand dollars and he was sued
by the guy who made the photograph and
Jeff Koons lost the case so this was the
legal precedent I was facing and it
anyway I removed my my image from my
website um just because ISPs are
notoriously weak spined and if they
receive a court order they generally
remove your website or threaten you and
my my gallery removed it too and the
minute we did that and I told the
rhizome list that we did that they
grabbed my image was right before I did
that they grabbed it and started
mirroring it on all the
sites and this is where it gets weird
okay because people started making
derivative work from my artwork in in
solidarity and I heard his name Ryan
griffis declared joy war which isn't a
reference to something called toy war
which is maybe I won't go into here but
it's it's a precedent of civil
disobedience online by artists when an
artist or collaborative is being sued
and so people started playing with the
image there's a Barbie I love that joy
wore a documentation of artists freedom
sampling media and the net with a little
Microsoft manual in the lower right hand
corner you can see that it says visual
referenced pretty good I think someone
at risin must have made that and I don't
know who and then this page that an
artist in England put together a media
artists with links to the various
derivative artworks and still up and
then something crazy happened it hit the
blogs and once it hit the blogs it went
global because of the feeds and the news
aggregators so mostly because of net art
news which has an RSS feed and which
went out to all the other blogs and news
aggregators that subscribe to it so it
started to appear elsewhere and on Brian
site which had a lot of great links to
Creative Commons sites and informative
sites so it became a kind of education
you know I learned a lot from joy war
myths about copyright blah blah various
local arts organizations pitched in
blogs in California once these are
online you can read them they're very
funny there's the toy war people in
Zurich I it hit italy italy italy oops
yeah this guy emailed me this is an
attachment he clearly thought pepsi
that's suing me so i guess a few things
got lost in translation i can have the
heart to tell him but wasn't pepsi but I
I thought it was great this made my day
cuz at that point I was demoralized and
i had to pay my lawyer and I really know
it was going on prog pretty cool crazy
people stay free magazine edited by
Carrie McLaren which is in a hub of what
can I call it it's it's a hub of
information and and revolt against
extreme copyright fundamentalism I was
very thankful for that once this was up
on their on their website I got calls
from New York Times reporters I wanted
to write about a copyright case that
didn't have to do with music and I
thought New York Times and I called my
lawyer and he said mmm wrong bad this
would be great if we were in court but
not a good idea so I didn't anyway it
goes on and on
askey wonderful ASCII sites this is just
a part of a huge pixelated jpg crazy um
sometimes things got really abstracted
and interesting and really didn't really
have much to do with the original image
at all which is kind of fabulous and
sometimes they had everything to do with
the original yeah that was everybody's
favorite brit lative and then some guy
sent me these rage against the machine I
thought this is getting really out of
hand splatter kitty com there were a lot
of animated and various software induced
animation sites with links I can't quite
reproduce them here these are just
screens screenshots but you can go there
still on the web this was an ingenious
thing where you could hit a link and it
would regroup Molotov remix by Mark
Cooley 1.jpg sliced into 121 images
randomly reloaded via JavaScript and the
brilliant thing is the chances of users
hitting upon the perfect realignment of
images is less than winning the lottery
but just in case he has a fair use
argument ready that was a shock wave
animation this was a QuickTime one that
said art not crime after the letters
finished an interface where you could
upload music and Molotov images and play
them with other people at further field
and this fantastic thing shockwave in
the midst of all this I got a really
late review finally on artnet which
reproduced a really bad jpg off the
image the reviewer had no idea that I
would
being threatened with a lawsuit and then
when he found out he put it on his blog
and then it went all over the place
again of course in the middle of this I
also got this from the lawyer thank you
for removing the images from the website
so some really really some part of me
really wanted ms my zealous to know what
was going on but as I never ever ever
received any kind of direct
correspondence from her I let it go no I
don't think she knows about joy war
anyway what was that site where I found
in grams of fragment clearly she wanted
to know because they wanted to get it
off that site to a little late I looked
everywhere I looked everywhere I looked
everywhere I did every possible search
that I know I would do it's just not
there anymore whoever they were whatever
side it was it's down they took it down
the site isn't there who knows but I did
find it here I found it at Harold
Pinter's website in which he has a
portion of it unattributed in black and
white which he describes as an image
which became emblematic of the
Sandinistas struggled to regain their
democracy so there was a time when it
was really a famous image it was
emblematic and it meant something it
meant something very important and then
it was forgotten it was forgotten in the
pages of an out-of-print book so I leave
it to you to decide whether whether
giving something inadvertently giving
something a second life or where the
opportunity for a second life through a
transformative use is a bad thing or not
yes it's up to the copyright holder but
anyway one blog had this very particular
question which I thought was maybe went
to the core of everything and really
wasn't about me or my painting or Susan
and her photographs in the end these
people they don't have
be right protection and their images are
are being used and it's legal it's legal
because there's case law that says that
you don't need to ask permission from
people in public when you shoot their
photographs and it was because of that
those decisions that were made when
George Eastman had just invented film
that photography became a booming
business became a technology became a
thing that developed into what it is now
and beyond that's it
questions yeah when it dries up in the
blog and all that it seems like there
was confusion about source seems like a
lot of facts got the story there wasn't
lost well I was being threatened with a
lawsuit which is still pretty different
than it's very different um pepsico like
I noticed on that last thing that person
was also the last image you show where
they asked the question what price is
dispensed for you oh um let's go back to
that our texts they also mention yeah
yeah yeah that seems to me that would
generate a much different reaction from
the net community then the photographer
who took this picture is upset that it's
this know that the corporation the Holy
toy thing that has always been about
corporations yeah she was not a big bad
corporation she was an artist we
discussed I didn't want they knew I you
know my original I didn't reproduce it
here because it's kind of long and sappy
but I my original post horizon was that
photographer photojournalists was had
sent me a legal letter and that I felt
that possibly i had been exposed by
another fine journalist and that there
was an attitude problem but that i had
no recourse but to do what they wanted
me to do and because they because she
owned copyright and I mean my my in the
discussions with my lawyer he said you
know if it was Pepsi you would have a
case because it's crazy and it's crazy
to begin with but the fact that you know
she has her needs and she has her
supporters and she can be made to look
sympathetic and soak
you it's really up for grabs I mean her
concerns are real I'm not saying they're
not copyright is no longer functioning
the way it once did she can control that
image that image for all of her images
all of their images are up on the web
they have Magnum watermarks but who
cares I mean one thing I didn't include
was one of these artworks that was made
actually was incredible it was someone
made with some kind of software a cube a
3d cube that you could turn with your
mouse but instead of putting my painting
on the side of it they put her
photograph on the side of it I thought
aha that doesn't help that really muddy
is it the waters because she does own
the copyright to that image yeah and she
doesn't own the copyright to my image
that was our dispute people can do what
they want with my image cuz it's my
artwork that was really hard to speak
and she didn't feel it was mine so but
she has a problem and photojournalist
had a problem and it's sort of them I
think I think it's crazy to to worry
when it really doesn't have any direct
effect on your earning capacity or your
market as a photo as a photo based
artist we all should know that the
galleries are different the collectors
are different it's not the same medium
the ramifications of the work the
concepts the conceptual basis of the
works are absolutely different so there
is no overlap in that in that sense of
competing which was something that my
Minneapolis friend didn't get so sorry I
didn't answer your question I think
overboard yeah
yeah my the image that I am here let's
do this my the image I found
yeah the image i found was already
cropped sorry
hmm
mmm to a painting
mm-hmm it's fascinating well even
obviously which you're hired yeah mm-hmm
I mean even without all of that's
amazing because I don't know that much
about cameras per se or but it's even
from a really much more simplistic art
historical viewpoint if you wanted to
argue for transformative you know
portraiture versus landscape I mean
that's just you know it's yeah sorry
you're very aware of what it is that
you're arguing
she does not strong I just think about
the to make a living
absolutely yeah it's essential it's
essential can I interrupt it's about how
the truth is treated cavalierly in our
culture and in the mass media um I was I
was doing both it doesn't matter well
the idea is that the image itself
doesn't tell you without the context hat
let's say hypothetically that I knew her
and that i love that image and that i
wanted to go against what i normally do
and she gave me permission but she
wanted a credit ok and i made a painting
and I stuck her credit on the on the
wall and I made a direct reference to
the original why would I do that I mean
it's sort of this is what she would see
according to what I came to understand
from our little spat through her lawyer
she just wanted she just didn't want to
be she wanted credit she want to be
raised and and I don't want to erase her
and kind of regret having used that
image but in truth I mean every every
image i use from the mass media has an
author and
I have to say first that as as I started
this project with mass media I became
increasingly aware of the complexity of
the same and that I'm i was more aware
of it by the end of the of the project
than I was in the beginning and that's
sort of my work method my sources teach
me about themselves so it's possible how
can I put this it's possible that
critique that all the pieces of critique
are not are not preassembled as you
approach project that that in the
process you you learn things and and
it's a flawed it's a flawed activity
it's a flawed process and what you say
is valid it's not I think it's important
to to actually to demonstrate the a
moral quality of images by by by by
extending that a morality that's what I
do and maybe that's perverse but it's
not so risky when well how why is it
risky
stop
I I'm selling I'm selling the idea as
painting is fiction see that's the thing
no one looks at a painting and says this
happened people look at photographs and
they they automatically say this is
evidence this is proof photograph is
proof photograph is a trace you know all
that stuff they don't look at a painting
and say that the idea the concept is
that painting is a medium that is not
evidence so it has this baggage so when
you take images that are supposed to be
representations of facts and you take
them into a medium this is the nugget of
it that is supposed to represent fantasy
fiction lyrical navel-gazing you name it
but anything but fact what you're doing
is you're saying the photograph may not
be fact that when kappa took the photo
the photograph of of the soldier falling
in the spanish civil war it may not be
what we thought it was when those two
people were kissing in Times Square in
that famous photograph people were so
upset to find out that was staged what
I'm saying is that every image is
mediated and framed every photograph
every mass media image we know that the
paintings are that's what painting is so
when you take images that you assume
aren't and you remake them as paintings
I mean this is this is my project
long-term doesn't have to be mass media
sources can be government you know other
things but but in the long term that's
my project that's what I want it to do
sorry
I think you can we go to dinner there
anybody else yeah
well I don't know it's the expression
it's it's defined in such as in a
specific way the expressive portion of a
work is that which is that comes from
the author so it's an expression of
their personal artistic skill or thought
or whatever so it can be i mean my my
expression is done in paint you know
it's made with certain kinds of skills
very separate from her kinds of skills
it's about those skills and about how
you use them to make your art that's
that's what they take it to me and
whereas the fact is the thing the
subject the object that you're
appropriating there and style their
voice on how almost ideological
difference
Susan my cell is very radically
different notion of what the office and
stipple why you want to protect your
workers and agree yeah yeah such a
second yeah yeah I mean I liked it when
people just I think of course it was for
that reason sorry go ahead overwhelmed
an artist with you know the cost of
lawsuits of serving a bankrupt people
guess what the thread lawsuits however
we live in a highly visual culture and I
do think that there are somethings wrong
when a small child seeing an image of
Martin Luther King's dream speech I
think things cell phones you know that's
a person that comes survive because of
the way it was that image has been
appropriated by a corporation that just
wants to move its product hmm and yet
you know it seems wrong that since
images so much control of lives that I
need the vigil corporation should have
travel power over how them and you know
as you're pointing out you want to take
image and transform its meaning into
something else a problem that I see
though is that you have seasons on iPod
which is at once an image enters sort of
this public marketplace the authors and
you know personal intention is lost what
you're left with is image itself so when
a court that has been precision as to
pieces for transformative or derivative
and the force of your argument or
transformation comes from your own
individual attention as an author hmm no
it's that sonnet i quote that sort of
shows well I'm not making ok when you
Susan my zealous and I had the same idea
basically which is true which is if you
can keep if you package if what you're
making is defined his art it is
perceived in a certain way and when she
produced that book it wasn't it it was a
work of art was it an art book ok it was
not sent out into the media and her
lawyer pointed that out to me and when
you make a painting a Susan Sontag's
argument is so specifically about the
medium of photography and it's so it's
so much deeper than I can go or care to
go because my background in the theory
of photography is is not that extensive
but when you're talking about that kind
of an authorship it's it's specific the
authorship of the photograph the
photojournalists photograph as it exists
in the world and when you talk about a
painting or I mean any of these things
the authorship is on the surface it's
it's obvious
the photograph is supposed to be
transparent the author of a
photojournalistic photograph is not
supposed to be present in the photograph
it's part of this huge pile of theory
that and so there isn't there's a
hypocrisy there or there's just a that's
the wrong word there's a there's a
conflict because the author is there and
it is their work but they're absent in
themselves for reasons they're trying to
their mission is to report to be neutral
they're not neutral so what I what you
have to see right away is that painting
doesn't it's not it's not neutral it's
not telling you it's neutral it doesn't
want to be neutral in the sense that it
is it is expression it is a product of
the hand and somebody's ideas and some
skill thrown in whereas the the photo
journalistic photograph is is very
complex it's all those things and yet it
is to some degree evidence and it's it's
the way the evidence is contextualized
that photo journalists are trying to
protect and yet what Susan Sontag is
saying and what I think is true and
since digital technology has changed
everything they can't they can't and and
that's why what she was saying is
dangerous but what I'm saying is instead
of saying oh god it's dangerous and we
have to like protect everything and keep
it from changing we can't like we can't
it's not it's the wrong way to think
about it there have to be more creative
ways to think about it and that's yeah
that's another lecture that's like there
anymore yeah
of of sampling images from from the
world around me or from well i think it
probably began in the 90s when I was
looking at science photography and i was
looking at textbooks because i was oh
yeah yeah and i'm not i mean i'm not
well known so the thing is once you
become super famous like jeff koons and
you make a lot of money people are going
to sue you and so I was really kind of
halfway gratified that's being sued I
felt yeah oh you mean have I changed the
way I do things since that do I feel oh
I don't have a fear yeah I'm more aware
of it and I'm thankful for that because
I I should have been aware of it but
coming as I did through kind of public
domain declassified photography it just
didn't occur to me and it never occurred
to me that that a painting wasn't a
large shift huge change from my source
material in other words I didn't know
the term transformative use and I didn't
know the problem between derivative and
transformative but i already had and I
felt that what I debt what I did was
transformative it just seemed obvious
and I mean often what seems obvious has
nothing to do with the law so I think I
haven't changed the way I'm doing things
and but it's very good to be aware of
other people's sensitive issues
and so I more sensitive